pourquoi dit-on se faire un sang d'encre
si vous vous faites un sang d'encre
cela signifie que vous êtes
particulièrement inquiet mais quel
rapport entre le liquide utilisé pour
écrire le son est notre angoisse du
moment et bien c'est tout simplement la
couleur noir associé ici à notre sens
elle représente une émotion sombre le
lien entre le liquide qui coule dans nos
veines et nos états d'âme ne nous paraît
peut-être pas évident aujourd'hui mais
il l'était au moyen âge pour les
médecins de l'époque notre santé au sens
large dépendait de l' équilibre entre
nos différentes humeurs un terme qui
désigne un lait liquide coule dans notre
corps le sens particulier mais aussi la
bile et la fameuse seigner servait à
éliminer l'excès de son supposé nous
rendre malades ce qui n'était pas
toujours une bonne idée pour certains
patients déjà bien affaiblie pour ma
part j'essaie de ne pas me faire de bill
nine mauvais sens et j'espère bien vous
retrouver lors de ma prochaine émission